this video is made in partnership with
innovators the graduates of the
innovation program created by kadukawa
ascii research lab inc and the japanese
ministry of internal affairs and
communications hey everyone my name is
miyuko and i'm a software engineer
turned content creator making videos
about tech career and life so i saw this
thing about japanese beer can
innovations on the japanese tv channel
the other day and it just got me
thinking about how japan innovates and
how different it is from what i'm used
to about how the us innovates there's a
lot of analysis on what makes japan
japan and a lot of it is around the
rules that rule japan and specifically
culture wise but i was just so curious
about what rules ruled japan when it
comes to innovation i mean i'm japanese
american i was brought up in japanese
household i speak japanese fluently but
when it comes to innovation i was
definitely brought up in like kind of
american mentality especially via
silicon valley so things like disrupting
industries and maximizing profits and
venture capital and like revolutionizing
the world by making a big impact are all
the things that i'm used to but japan
all the meanwhile was inventing things
like new beer cans a robot that helps
you grieve a loved one an ar camera that
turns people and objects into
interactable experiences and a 300 toast
machine that makes like the perfect
toast so yes needless to say japanese
definitions around innovation and their
attitude towards it felt very different
from american standards so i wanted to
learn more basically i wanted to find
out what makes japanese innovations so
unique meet etsuko
in 2016 she was part of japan's
innovation program designed to support
the bold ideas of creative thinkers to
bring their innovations to life with
different challenges that run every
summer to inspire folks to take action
by the way i made a video about this
program last year and what i think is an
important key for japan to create
groundbreaking inventions so if you
haven't checked it out do so right here
she's the creator of the digital shaman
project a new way to grieve and give
condolences using modern technology
foreign
all right so let's be real this is a
very japanese invention ichihan was a
part of a program called innovators
which really takes advantage of all the
things that make japanese innovations
japanese they welcome strange science
and unusual technology to the table and
create a program for these inventors to
introduce their works to the world a
couple of other projects from innovators
also piqued my interest like kazumi
mudaki's car alpha a machine that
essentially sucks up co2 emissions or
makoto morishta's arama an ar camera
that allows you to digitize people and
objects to play with in augmented
reality all of these feel inherently
japanese to me i feel like there's a
sort of playfulness or maybe it's like a
human-centric approach of innovating
that feels very different from silicon
valley's method of innovating and
inventing things so what exactly makes
them so japanese
there's a saying in japanese culture
that i've said before called
the nail that sticks out gets hammered
in and this really speaks to japanese
conformist culture where if you stand
out or deviate from the crowd then
you're gonna have a tough time so taking
things like risks which is inherently
involved when you're gonna innovate a
new thing
is a really big deal and taking that
kind of risk could jeopardize your
reputation it really changes the way
that people think about you and you
could be kind of like the one that
sticks out from the crowd and i think
because of that precisely of the fear of
being the nail that sticks out japanese
innovations tend to be very
human-centric because if they innovate
on things that are like human-centric or
society-centered then societal approval
can come easier that way of course this
doesn't mean that japan isn't innovative
it just means that when innovation
happens it's usually going to be aimed
at like creating a net positive for the
world
okay so this is a really common
perspective when it comes to looking at
japanese innovations it's that japan is
really focused at and is really good at
improving existing inventions and
thinking about how they can apply that
to daily life this sounds a lot like
kaizen which is a japanese word for
improvement which also has been applied
to kind of like business philosophy
around continuous improvement and
improving of processes and operations
and honestly i think this like specific
mentality allows people to just like
fall in love with the process or the
journey of creating more than the end
result itself
yeah
[Music]
and so these days when we're talking
about new technology in japan the ones
that are the most common are things like
ai machine learning augmented reality
virtual reality and robotics and
especially for things like ai or robots
or something where like in western
cultures especially in america we have
this kind of just like ooh kind of
spooky we're not really sure if we want
to trust robots yet they're actually
really embraced in japan and i think it
has roots in kind of the shinto religion
in that everything animate or not has
spirit in them and so it makes sense to
me that ichiharasan's project is about
applying one spirit to a robot because
people in japan are just more likely to
see robots as just like living things
that have their own spirituality and
personhood and i think another part of
that is that in japanese popular culture
robots have been friends for a long time
so if we think about atomu or doraemon
it's just been around for like
generations and generations and so it's
felt very like close to home for a very
long time to become friends with things
like robots
of course like everything and anything
there are going to be obstacles to
innovation and in japan's case i think
one of the things is that japan is just
kind of inherently a risk-averse society
and like i said before societal
reputation is kind of an important thing
and so there's just a lot at stake in
taking that kind of risk but when i was
interviewing ichihara-san one thing that
she said that really stuck out to me was
that maybe it's because of the societal
pressure that innovation and creativity
actually thrive like maybe it's the
pressure to blend in and assimilate
that's like creating this like pressure
cooker of an atmosphere that allows
people to be very creative with their
ideas and go against the grain and the
other obstacle which i talked about in
that previous video is that japan
definitely has a bias towards monozukuri
or creating things that you can touch
and feel and so innovation is going to
thrive in places where there's something
physical about it like a physical object
more so than something like a digital
software and it's not like this is a
good or bad thing it's just what makes
japanese innovations just so japanese
anyway looking at all of these factors
it makes a lot more sense why japanese
innovations just feel so
japanese to me for lack of a better word
i know i keep saying that but like
really it just feels very japanese
there's definitely a sense of
society-centered human-centric
playfulness that experiments with going
against the grain in such like a
conformist society and it's really
exciting to see all the different fun
novel and quite frankly weird inventions
that are coming out of japan right now
and so really i'm excited to see what
japan does next and if you are too then
i definitely recommend checking out
innovators or the innovation program to
kind of learn more about all the things
that are happening in japan right now
you can check out their youtube channel
which has a lot of really interesting
and weird inventions quite frankly uh
they're really fun to watch that make
you kind of think like wow this is like
just so different they also have a
website where you can check out all
those things as well and thank you so
much to innovators for partnering with
me on this video and providing a lens
into which i can view and really like
think about this question that i've had
ringing in my head for so long i'll
leave links to everything in the
description box down below including the
audama app which is available on the app
store currently so i'm definitely going
to play with that right after this and
make sure to subscribe to my channel if
you're interested in this kind of
content thank you so much for watching
and i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]